rogue one is a first stand-alone movie
in a Star Wars franchise several new
characters are being introduced as a
Rebel Alliance seeks up the plans for
the first Death Star Forest Whitaker
portrays a previously existing character
sagar era which leaves many wondering
who the heck is soccer era here are six
things you should know about him before
watching road 1 number 6 Tom made his
first appearance in animated form in the
Clone Wars fifth season in a four-part
story show you up for this so it was an
accident
George Lucas originally planned for the
character to be used in a live-action
Star Wars TV series which obviously
didn't happen number 5 thought is a
resistance fighter on the planet Onderon
during the Clone Wars obi-wan Kenobi
Anakin Skywalker ahsoka tano and clone
trooper Captain Rex were sent to help
train and advise rebels fighting the
separatists we're looking forward to
taking a fight those scrappin droids
only he knew things Anakin would do
later as Darth Vader I find your lack of
faith disturbing Herrera was arrogant
and a bit of a jerk towards others he
also saw himself as the leader of the
resistance zone saw Herrera he fashions
himself as our leader though no one
elected him number 4
unfortunately foresaw being the leader
wasn't how everyone felt after a victory
against the separatist droid army saw
sister Stila was voted as a leader by
the other resistance fighters all in
favor of Steele as our leader raise your
hand
[Music]
okay
it's like it's been decided number three
during a big battle saw wanted to shoot
down the last droid ship when it crashed
it resulted in his sister hanging off
the edge of a cliff
ahsoka used a force to levitate her up
but was shocked by the Fallen ship and
lost her focus Stila fell to her death
saw blamed himself for taking action
without thinking it was my fault I shot
that gunship down and crashed into a
position number two Sol later becomes a
key figure in a rebellion against the
Empire the red symbol on onderon Ian's
armor wears a strong resemblance to the
Rebel Alliance star bird number one at
some point he loses a freaking leg while
fighting the Empire that's dedication
Luke Skywalker only lost a hand but you
know what they say freedom sometimes
costs an arm and a leg
Sargeras name has been mentioned in the
current Star Wars rebels TV show as well
as a Star Wars bloodline novel Jane Eyre
so met saw when she was young which is
detailed in a star wars catalyst book
hopefully we'll find out more about him
in rogue one as well as what happened to
his leg what do you think happened to
his leg did darth vader chop it off let
us know in the comments below for more
on comics movies and TV shows keep it
tuned to GameSpot universe if you want
to stay up to date with all of our movie
videos be sure to subscribe to GameSpot
universe on YouTube it's game spots
permanent home for TV movies and comics
as of January 3rd subscribe now so you
never miss a video
[Music]
you
[Music]